the leading cause of suicide is
depression the second leading cause
could be direct messages from chrissy
teigen
[Laughter]
on the same day tegan apologized for her
online bullying fashion designer michael
costello reveals that teagan harassed
him
nearly to the point of suicide on
instagram costello explained how teagues
reveled in destroying his career based
on a phony meme
writing quote she apparently formed her
own opinion of me based on a
photoshopped comment
floating around the internet which has
now been proven to be false by instagram
and since taken down
she told me that my career was over and
that all my doors will be shut from
there on
i didn't see the point of living
costello also shared a direct message
purportedly from tegan where she told
him quote racist people like you deserve
to suffer and
die you might as well be dead your
career is over
just watch wait that doesn't sound like
her at all
so far chrissy hasn't challenged these
new allegations but to what extent is
social media to blame
should the permanence of the internet
make it impossible to free yourself of
past dumb comments
not so much for tegan who's an awful
awful creep
but for the millions of idiot kids who
deserve not to have old posts follow
them into adulthood
by the way that's why i avoid making
dumb comments online and save them for
this show
you know it's like my uncle used to say
to me when i was a kid when i was
working on the farm
greg that's not what the goats are for
[Laughter]
i don't know why everybody's laughing at
that it's just all right so
again i always i always go to you diana
because you are the scientist
this is somebody who already has high
status she's married to a a
a famous singer she was a famous model
um
she had the power to either elevate or
denigrate
what is the evolutionary reason what is
the biological
reason for being so awful
when you don't have to be i'm i'm at a
loss like why choose evil
i don't know what the history with her
in this man is but you know even
you know putin has to kill his enemies
in order to
you know succeed more if he's already
succeeded you could say he owns a whole
country
what else does he possibly need to do so
even very powerful people
will try and punish their enemies or
denigrate people
in order to cement their power to show
people look i'm powerful enough to end
your career and to punish you
so don't cross me yeah and you know we
don't know to what extent
this kind of behavior was what led to
her success to begin with
so we often say these kinds of people
can't possibly be successful
but often these kinds of tactics are how
people climb the status hierarchy
and she in terms of bullying has been
given this veneer
it's okay to bully people if they're
racist right even if the racism
is found out later to be untrue so she
can be as horrible as she wants to be
because
if somebody racist commits suicide
that's totally fine because
that's justified yeah yeah that's true
kat
isn't she a horrible person
what isn't she a horrible person she is
a horrible person
and so much of this narrative is oh how
could this social justice warrior
be a bully it's like duh because they
all are
yeah and i'm and i'm not talking
obviously about people who you know want
to see
progress on issues like racism sexism
people to be nice to each other
talking about people who want to cancel
people over a single comment and think
that progress doesn't matter because one
mistake
means you're awful and you should just
die and she has been very publicly the
latter for so long
she's obviously this vindictive person
that gets pleasure out of taking other
people down
is that this shouldn't be shocking to
anybody and i wish people could learn
that this is what's driving so many
people who have this whole social
justice warrior thing
again if you want to make important
points about progress that's fine but if
you want to see someone
canceled destroyed and never being able
to participate in society again because
they said something's dumb when they
were 16.
you're probably not a nice person no
you're not you know joe
to cat's point about the his attack her
attack on
frank costello the designer this was a
actually this guy reached out and
and pleaded with her yeah and she
delighted in his suffering
like he reached out in the hardest
situation possible
and she said she bat like somebody
reaching their hand out for help
and she batted it down that expresses to
cat's point the mob mentality or the
lust for power that you find in the
worst people
yeah you know she talks about i was a
troll that's not trolling what she did
she reached out to people through direct
messages yes that's
that's not trolling she's issued this
apology but she's issued apologies
before and she even did a big
goodbye i'm living twitter and she was
gone for about 15 minutes right so what
we're seeing is
she's a you know i'm a bit of a
scientist myself
this is the kind of pure narcissism
that's rewarded on social media because
if you look at her apology it goes on
and on and it just says i
i i yeah and i guarantee within a week
it's going to turn into the story's not
going to be the people she was cruel to
it's going to be look how much i've
learned from the journey
i put myself on aren't i amazing how
much i've grown
and the book will be called x troll yeah
and it'll be chrissy teigen's growth
from from you know the darkest part of
her life
this rejuvenated thing okay here's a q i
just this question came to me and i
don't know if you have the answer
where is her husband if my wife was
doing this stuff
what's so funny she was doing this stuff
and i can't no
elena elena elena has never tweeted in
her life exactly
but but uh uh when you if your
husband was doing this emily you'd be
like get the
oh i almost said a swear word like
well first of all i think it's pretty
clear who wears the pants in that family
and it's her so he's probably not doing
anything but making brilliant music in
the side room while she like overlords
her empire
but you guys i i see her she is like
that
demon remember in the new snow white
where the the evil queen had to like
suck up people's beauty in order to be
more beautiful herself like
she is beyond the vile and vicious and
vindictive
of just your average troll this is an
awful human being because she did ruin
michael costello's career he said that
for years after
he did he would get jobs only to then be
ghosted this was like harvey weinstein
level sabotage this person's life this
his professional livelihood was
absolutely ruined
and hers as far as i'm concerned is
still smooth sailing she lost a couple
contracts sure but yeah she's still on
there
i mean she's still on the cover of
magazines she still has what millions of
followers
i mean i don't i don't see yet what the
accountability is but the fact that she
told nine-year-olds to kill themselves
there has to be accountability beyond
her just continuing
did she say yes and sixteen-year-olds
lindsay lohan add more slits to your
wrist oh yeah
she is a monster yeah you know what i
have to say this
before we go so i got an email uh
i don't know how many years ago about
this story about uh because
i had talked about how much i liked
project runway and i was watching it so
i get this email from somebody telling
me the story about frank costello and
that he's being ruined and destroyed and
i remember going like i don't want to
get in the middle of this
because i can't because he's been
accused of racism
and i didn't want like you know what do
i come out and defend this guy
i don't know maybe he is a racist and it
was like he was like kryptonite
and the guy in the person who reached
out either was a friend of his or
something
saying this is like really really bad
and i did
nothing because what could i do right
people talk about toxic masculinity men
wanting to beat each other up this is
actually the core of what i could call
toxic femininity yeah which is women
mean girling other people you know
gossiping
saying horrible things about people who
are their enemies and totally
disenfranchising them and ostracizing
them
and this is actually one of the core
aspects of the social justice movement
is this kind of aggression is totally
accepted
not just the core value of social
justice movement but also the
bachelorette
i guess or the bachelor i can't remember
which one has the most girls in it
the bachelor the bachelor there no
wonder i get so confused watching it hey
sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else